un livre jour olivier baroux jacques
chancel jacques chancel vous est
l'éditeur des écrits de l'image et vous
publiez votre 17e livre qui est au fond
un journal d'amour pour la télévision
alors cette passion toujours fervente
j'aime d'abord le mot passion je suis
acteur je suis voyeur
je suis aussi un peu coursier de
l'éphémère acteur je fais le grand
échiquier ou bien j'organise des
programmes voyeur j'écris mon journal et
j'observe et puis poursuit de l'éphémère
je me promène sur chaque crête à chaque
instant à chaque seconde
sans me demander ce que sera le monde au
présent vous évoquez des hommes et des
lieux et parmi ceux-ci encore au
cambodge que j'ai eu la chance de
visiter récemment pour vous aujourd'hui
l'indochine en quelques mots l'ado chine
d'aujourd'hui pas encore la liberté
l'indochine d'hier simon carrey
d'enfance son territoire dès de
l'essence et puisque vous parlez dans
mon corps je suis resté six mois sans
bouger regardons les pierres et les
temples je dirais simplement un mot
bravo à l'école française d'extrême
orient qui a permis véritablement qu une
merveille ne soient pas anéantis
arthur rubinstein vieil oiseau ivre
comme disait jean cau et peut-être la
figure la plus émouvante de votre
ouvrage
il y a le pianiste évidemment mais il ya
surtout l'homme est celui que je
considérais un peu un certain moment que
mon père et puis il ya le pamphlétaire
celui qui était animé d'une férocité
tout à fait d'étonnantes une anecdote
quel est le plus grand violoniste du
monde me disait il alors je citais
beaucoup beaucoup de violonistes puis à
la fin il me disait comme toujours tu ne
sais rien le plus grand violoniste du
monde c'est yehudi menuhin jusqu'à l'âge
de 7 ans
oh